كارثه مستمره لم تنتهي بانتهاء الزلزال بل
تفاقمت مع نزوح سكان المناطق المنكوبه في
سوريا حاجه ملحه للمساعدات بكافه انواعها
تعرقلها الانقسامات السياسيه في سوريا
الخلاف السوري السوري تعمق حتى وصل الى
درجه رفض المعارضه السوريه لاي مساعدات
قادمه عبر مناطق سيطره النظام السوري
وقفه احتجاجيه قامت بها منظمات مجتمع مدني
شمال غربي سوريا رفضا لمحاولات الامم
المتحده لادخال المساعدات الى مناطق سيطره
فصائل المعارضه من قبل الحكومه السوريه في
ظل كارثه انسانيه يعيشها المنكوبون اطرا
زلزال
موجودين اليوم ضمن هاي الوقفه
بصاحه باب الهوى لنصل للامم المتحده اللي
بلشت تعطي تبريرات من اول يوم لها ونحن عم
بنطالب بوصول فرق انقاذ بعد منها حتى
المساعدات عم ترفض تسلمها عن طريق المعابر
الحدوديه الموجوده بيننا وبين سوريا كرمال
تدخلها عن طريق النظام
كمحاوله منها لشرعنه النظام مساء امميه
لادخال المساعدات عبر معابر بين مناطق
سيطره النظام وفصائل المعارضه قبلت بالرفض
كونها شرعنه للنظام على حد تعبير المحتجين
لن نقبل باي مساعدات تدخل من النمط النظام
النظام الاجنبي ان يغويس اهلنا الموجودين
في مناططه فهم بحاجه اكثر منا
مناطق يربطها بتركيا معبر واحد فقط ما
يؤخر وصول المساعدات ومحاولات امميه
مستمره لفتح معابر جديده الا ان الامم
المتحده تقول ان الجهات المسيطره في شمال
ادلب لا تعطي الموافقه لاتمام عمليات نقل
المساعدات
بالتزامن مع نفي فصائل المعارضه لتلك
الاتهامات